[Music]
we are here today to talk about
improving digital well-being Google's
approach and tips for developers my name
is Mindy Brooks and I'm a UX lead here
at Google I focus on kids and family as
well as the UX lead for Google Play with
me today are three of my colleagues
Sofia Maggie and Rose all focusing on
digital wellbeing and we're here to
share our insights and tips for you
today so let's dive right in today's
conversation will be focused on three
major areas first of which is insights
into digital wellbeing what we've
learned from talking to users around the
world about digital well-being and their
thoughts and opinions they're our
products and features that we've
launched as well as our ongoing
commitment in this space and the third
is our tips for developers some
takeaways for you today so how do people
feel about their digital well-being as a
UX lead here at Google I can say that we
are committed to talking to our users
around the world to understand what
they're thinking and feeling in fact
this past year alone we spoke to 95
thousand people to understand what does
digital well-being mean for you
and what we learned is it's highly
nuanced and highly personal what it
means for me might not mean what it
means for you but there is one thing
people can agree on that kids digital
well-being remains a top concern and we
hear that globally while parents and
adults see the many benefits of
technology for kids education connection
security they also have a lot of
concerns in fact 84 percent of parents
globally report that kids tech usage
remains a top parenting concern concerns
around inappropriate content online
safety bullying and even social skill
development are themes we hear around
the globe
and much of that concern is because kids
are getting devices earlier than ever
before how many of you have ever seen a
young child with a device how many of
you have noticed that kid might be
better at using that device than
yourself that's for me for sure it's
quite amazing to watch so parents are
really starting to wrestle with how do
we help kids develop healthy tech habits
and balance as they grow so one stat
that's very interesting is that we know
kids in the US or getting their first
smartphone at the age of 8 and is just
starting earlier and earlier so how do
parents help develop healthy boundaries
and balance for children but as you can
imagine kids don't live in isolation and
in fact are learning about how to use
technology from observing families and
parents dynamic with tech and the rules
in the household and so this heavily
influences how kids develop and grow so
this year we really set out to
understand what does digital well-being
mean in the family context and if we
understand the family context can it
help us inform how we create more
products for people so we did research
in 11 countries with 16,000 parents
teens and kids and what we learned
across the globe is that families live
in a state of paradox with digital
well-being in technology on one hand it
brings families together on the other
hand it drives them apart and we often
hear a phenomenon called alone together
you're all in the same room on same
devices but we're not talking or
connecting with each other on one hand
it relaxes and distress is that after a
very long day of work or school and on
the other hand it causes stress on one
hand it promotes child development
through education and information and on
the other hand can potentially hinder
child development on one hand parents
think kids overuse tech and on the other
hand parents can't manage it themselves
parents will promote usage for education
learning and on the other hand they're
discouraging usage go outside things we
commonly hear so families are living in
the state of paradox and tension on a
daily basis so these themes emerged from
the research of family connection of
stress a child well-being of overuse in
a balanced and so taking these five
things into consideration we really
wanted to think about what we could
build for our users to help with address
these needs but I want to point out one
thing it's not just adults or parents
that we've heard from we hear a lot from
kids and teenagers too and they
frequently point out that adults aren't
the best at modeling balance and
well-being for them we hear stories of
texting at the dinner table while the
kid has to have their phone put away or
texting while driving or being
distracted in the kid having to reap
repeat their questions over and over and
four kids think and teenagers
particularly they say it's hypocritical
so this is something that we take very
seriously how do we help all of our
users start to understand have what
their digital well-being means for them
so with that I will pass it to Sofia to
tell you a little bit more about what
we've learned here thanks Mindy hi I'm
Sofia I'm a UX researcher on Android
when we talk to adults about their
smartphones in particular they tell us
that notifications can distract them and
even cause stress we talked to people
about notifications and how they manage
their attention and they tell us they're
afraid to miss important notifications
and they're so inundated with
notifications but only some are actually
important in one of our studies a
research participant said notifications
make us attached to our phones it's
horrible but notifications are just one
element of digital well-being on smart
phones across studies we started to hear
a growing resentment towards phones for
example someone said it's almost
inhumane to always have a phone in my
and someone else said I look at this
thing more than anything else in my day
even more than my girlfriend then we
were in Japan doing some research and we
talked to feature phone users so they
were actively avoiding using a
smartphone and they were happy a feature
phone user said other people on
smartphones are on social networks and
they feel the need to be connected all
the time I don't want to live like that
I have a clear rhythm in life I have
self-control I have time for other
things and they really inspired us to
think about jomo or the joy of missing
out and the joy comes from feeling like
you're in control and you're not really
missing out on anything at all so we
decided to dig deeper into the
experience of connection and
disconnection and went out and talked to
people about their smartphones
and they repeatedly tell us just how
useful and essential their phones are
people rely on their phones for
communication navigation phones can be
our alarm clock our camera even the way
that we pay for things and this alone
may seem obvious but it's actually the
implications of this that are important
to think about if someone does want to
disconnect from the phone it's very
difficult to do so because they still
need these things so phones are so
useful and essential where does the
resentment come from well we learned
that it's unintentional behaviors that
bring about these feelings of guilt so
what does that mean it might be
intentionally using your phone for
something and then getting distracted
and then using it for something else
for example someone said I checked my
phone to see the time and then get
sucked right in
or it could be spending longer than you
intended on the device someone else said
I spent an hour and a half on a social
media app I was appalled with myself and
people tell us about how they've noticed
their own behaviors on their phone
evolve over time for example we've heard
about feeling phantom queues
like the phone is buzzing when it's not
or they notice that they might
repeatedly refresh an app just hoping
for new content to appear and people say
that they were afraid to be away from
their phone in case somebody needs to
reach them or they get a message and
they need to reply it quickly so it can
be very difficult to put the phone down
to disconnect from it as people are more
and more connected there's this desire
to disconnect or to at least use the
phone in a more intentional way so what
has Google done to support people's
intentional relationship with their
technology
last year we stood on this stage and
announced our commitment to digital well
being which is really rooted in our
belief that technology should improve
lives and not distract from them we
launched tool to give people greater
control over how they use their devices
and technology one of those tools is
family link so for parents
you can monitor and keep an eye on
screen time setting daily limits and
blah bedtimes you can manage the content
that your child sees remotely approving
downloads and blocking apps and you can
keep an eye on location remotely lock
the device and for all those times that
your child loses their phone in the
couch cushions you can ring the device
you tubelaunch take a break so if you
want to be reminded to take breaks while
watching videos YouTube will send you a
reminder gmail launched snooze so if you
want to put emails off for a later time
you can do that and they launched high
priority notifications so you only get
notified when there's an important email
in your inbox and we've seen that high
priority notifications have eliminated
97% of notifications on average while
still keeping users up to date when they
get an important email from the people
that matter most on Android we launched
digital while being tools including the
dashboard which shows you how
you're using your device app timers
which let you put limits on apps and
wind down to help you disconnect from
the device at night and in one study
we've seen that app timers helped users
stick to their goal 96% of the time and
wind down reduced nightly used by 27% so
we're starting to see the impact of our
features but we know that there's more
to do I'm gonna pass it over to Maggie
thank you in my role I look across
Google's digital well-being initiatives
to align our strategy and ensure that we
have a point of view that shares a users
point of view and what we heard this
year is that many people have digital
well-being on their minds and has become
even more important for people and their
families around the world as you heard
from both Mindy and Sophia we know that
helping parents is critical to this
initiative so with our launches of
family link for mobile as well as on
Chrome OS devices we've brought the
support to our global users and in the
past 12 months we've seen one in three
people actively take steps to make a
change with their relationship with tech
and the interesting thing is that these
people have taken steps that I have
certainly taken myself things like
deleting apps I'm not actively using or
reducing the number of notifications and
finally sometimes leaving that phone in
a different room in order to not be
interrupted and the good news is that
80% of them have reported a positive
impact their overall well-being this is
really really hopeful news but we know
that we can do even more together which
is exactly why we're here with you our
developer community you can help us
really scale this together another
resource that we've leveraged is drawing
upon the expertise of others so we've
assembled a bunch of experts in various
fields ranging from neuroscience to
behavioral science
to psychology and parenting and we're
employing their best practices in a lot
of our work for me as a user experience
practitioner I love to think about the
user it's a great way to ground us in
empathy and so with the many in fact 95
thousand people we listen to this year I
thought I would share with you a little
bit about how they're feeling about this
topic in their own words I feel like I
should be controlling my biggest issue
with it it's knowing when to stop just
tends to capture me away for what I
should be focusing technology is not so
much it's a necessary evil it's a
necessary good that could go either way
you know the jury's out it is up to us
as to what we do with the technology so
you heard from our wise users the jury
is out to us up to us to really
determine what's next and with that
we're going to introduce some of our
awesome features which built in a lot of
the insights we learned from our users
through these many studies and with that
I'll hand it over to Rose to share some
of these updates great thank you
yep hi I'm Rose product manager for
Digital well-being and as we've heard
from Sofia and Mindy and Maggie we have
been making a lot of progress we're
encouraged to see the data which shows
our users are really changing their
behaviors and meeting their goals but
also our research tells us there's more
work to do so we're excited to announce
some new features which continue to
build on what we announced last year
first as we heard notifications can be a
source of stress so there's a whole
bunch of stuff that my phone will tell
me that's really useful but not all of
it is useful right now for example this
morning I was working out
and before anyone thinks I'm a hero I'm
on London time so I'm basically in the
afternoon right now and I'm sitting at a
plank and I'm watching the timer hoping
that timer's gonna go down quickly and I
get the notification that says hey the
daily crossword is ready and I love my
crosswords but right then I didn't need
that so in Android q what we're
introducing is priority notifications
and what this does is creates two types
of notifications
there's priority and there's gentle and
only the gently the priority
notifications will make noise or vibrate
and interrupt you so in my example that
crossword notification that could be
gentle and something I come back to
later as opposed to interrupting me
right now in the moment and we've
learned from the research that it's the
unintentional moments that can lead to
feelings of regret and guilt so there
are important moments in your day when
your phone should reflect the intention
of what you're trying to do with
winddown
we do that at night so that when the
users trying to sleep wind down the
serves as a reminder that that's what
you're trying to do but imagine I'm at
work or at school and I want to be
productive there's a lot of stuff on my
phone that can help me be productive if
I'm at work I'm getting emails I'm
looking up where my next meeting is I'm
getting pings there's a multitude of
things but there's some stuff that would
be better to wait until I'm ready to put
what I don't need to focus so we're
introducing focus mode which will let
you pause distracting apps with a single
tap to get work done when the app is
paused the notifications are paused and
you can't open the app so for example
when preparing for this speech or trying
to do work it and work at work you can
turn on focus mode to pause the apps
that actually you don't need at that
moment and we've seen that our app
timers are effective for helping users
be more mindful of the apps they maybe
want to use at different times but we've
heard a lot of feedback from people all
around the world that it's not just apps
that distract them it's also websites
so for example one that I can personally
relate to that feeling of oh I'll just
go maybe do some online shopping or
scroll these news sites and so what
we're doing in Android queue is we're
introducing the ability for you to set
see your data from Chrome and also to
set timers on not just apps but also
websites but changing habits is hard I
always remind myself of this when we
when it feels like work is hard and what
we've heard from users is that they want
more positive encouragement and
motivation to stick to their goals
so you'll start to see more of this
starting first with the ability to set a
screen type goal with helpful nudges to
stay on track and as Maggie mentioned
we're doing this partnering with many
experts to understand more how do we
think about user behavior and in
addition to these new features we're
also making a number of improvements to
existing features to make sure that they
continue to be effective and help users
achieve what they want to achieve so for
example we're making it easier to see
how you're doing with your app timers
and we're introducing a daily schedule
for winddown because as much as we might
hear from the experts that it's really
important you go to sleep at the exact
same time every night we know that that
doesn't always fit in your life and we
know from my research and we heard from
Mindy that parents are concerned about
the amount of time that their kids are
spending on technology and they're
actively looking for support so we're
adding more features to family and then
help parents set the digital ground
rules and find the right balance of
technology for their kids as one example
we're introducing app specific time
limits so that parents can say instead
of just I don't want you used to your
phone but I have this limit for a
specific app which great if you use it
this amount but beyond that we'll shut
it down for the rest of the day and
we're also introducing the ability for
parents to grant kids more screen time
so imagine your kid reaches their screen
time limit for the day but has a little
more homework to do or something else
parent
congrat bonus time to the kids and we'll
also introduce the ability for a kid to
request bonus time which a parent can
say yes or no to but it's not just
parents who have the ability to help
others disconnect we all have the
ability to help each other disconnect
and so Google Earth not Google sorry
Gmail just recently launched the ability
to schedule sent emails as part of their
15th anniversary so as an example Monday
was a public holiday in the UK where I'm
based but it wasn't here so I was
working here but my team doesn't need to
be interrupted with the emails that I
was sending so I can schedule sent to
say I want it to arrive on Tuesday when
they're back in the office and not
interrupt them on the Monday and all of
this is helping us build more of an
intentional way for users to interact
with technology so they can meet more of
their digital well-being goals but
that'll pass back to Maggie awesome
Thank You rose alright so bringing it
home with this notion of embracing
digital well-being for a sustained
relationship with users which I'm sure
you all are thinking a lot about as well
and I personally want to provide you
with some tools some resources this is
early days in this space and will
continue to kind of build upon what we
share today but what we know is that
having a meaningful impact really
requires getting these tools out to more
people and you're a huge huge part of
that so I want to share with you
resources for you resources for parents
and educators and resources for you as
developers but first we have to start
with ourselves kind of that heal thyself
first mantra that I think many of us
don't spend enough time on and our
friends in our Google brand studio and
marketing team relaunched our well being
Google site we know that this is not a
one-size-fits-all solution it's very
nuanced and so they've created a great
tool a self-reflection tool a guide for
parents and kids about tech cues and
video content with some of those experts
who we've sought out so I hope you'll
find this valuable and I hope you'll
check it out
the other thing too
we have available is a great resource
called be internet awesome for kids how
many of you have actually checked this
out show of hands
alright there's lots of homework I think
you guys would love it
three great assets within here
curriculum for teachers in Thailand
video game for kids and a helpful guide
for parents to have those conversations
and get kids safe online at an early age
and the good news this is available in
16 countries and finally resources for
you you are a huge huge part of us
making this change as a collective
effort and so I wanted to start with our
digital wellbeing values we hold these
dear and we build these into our
products first provide awareness we want
to ensure that we're encouraging mindful
intentional use we want to then enable
control and personal ownership so that
people really understand the decisions
they are making with their technology we
want to then deliver benefits without
guilt shame or regret we learn a lot of
this through the sentiment analysis and
survey as we run and maybe that's an
insight for you to think about as well
and then we want to ensure trust
ultimately
we're all here to build that trust with
users and this can be a critical
resource for that transitioning into a
case study the thing that I have found
so interesting about working on digital
well-being as a longtime user experience
practitioner is that oftentimes what we
find is that it's what's good for the
user is good for the well-being and that
makes a lot of sense and what's
interesting about jobs this is a
language learning app they use a
technique called spaced repetition and
they have an intentional amount of time
where they give a lapse between the last
learning session and the subsequent
session and what's interesting is these
stats could look possibly
counterintuitive to somebody who's
looking at it from a growth kind of
perspective the average daily user
spends 56 percent less time within the
app and uses it 51 percent less often
and so from a digital well-being
standpoint this sounds like a really
good thing but the amazing thing is that
this model really lines up the user
goals with
the business goal is to really make
their app strategy work so I'll share
with you first the user goals and I'll
share with you the business goals and
hopefully this will convey a little bit
more about how they approached it so
from a user goals perspective they want
to lower the barrier to entry so they've
introduced a five-minute session limit
they figure anybody who's looking
forward to learning a language can
certainly spend at least five five
minutes on that session they then want
to make sure they've got a sustainable
engagement model so they have a limit on
the next session which is 10 hours
what's cool about that is that is that
space repetition which really allows for
memorization so a great way to align
those user goals with their app strategy
then when we take a look at the business
strategy they have users who pay more
subscribe more and churn less which is a
pretty amazing feat in and of itself so
their stats are also very impressive you
see a 4x higher average revenue per
daily user versus their pure average
they see a 2.5 higher install rate two
paid subscriber conversion per verse
pure average and then finally 84 percent
lower subscriber churn so this is an
amazing evidence of how you can align
user goals business goals and really
have a solvent business model and the
good news is I'm seeing more and more of
this in the ecosystem I was meeting with
top app developers yesterday in a
developer event we had I'm sure many of
you are also thinking along these lines
and I think this is what has been so
heartening to me about this work is
lining up the user goals that ultimately
lead to the business goals I also want
to share with you best practices this
team this collective team which I
represent right now but there are many
many across the company working on this
have observed two critical signals for a
digital well being their quality and
quantity so let me tell you a little bit
more about quality so what this might
look like as you're thinking about your
app or maybe even reflecting on what we
just shared with with drops this is all
about helping them complete tasks
without complete
any extra steps it's also about enjoying
their time and energy spent on the site
and then finally one thing that we've
really looked into is collecting signals
of quality so that we understand how
they spent their time and what's
interesting about this is oftentimes the
people in their life the people who
matter is a really critical signal and
that's much of what Rose was also
intimating with some of the
prioritization in Gmail etc when we look
at quantity we want to make sure we're
encouraging that intentional use so this
means prioritizing the things that help
you with your overall well-being that
includes sleeve work relationships all
those things that help your physical and
emotional self also be well we then want
to recommend that if you're building
enterprise tools you provide some way
for the user to maybe separate that
personal life in that work life and I
think for many of us that's become very
intermingle but it's a time where it
might benefit us to really look at ways
to break that apart at times and then
finally consider the user needs and
support those needs this sounds like a
no-brainer
and ultimately this comes back to really
that user experience principle of
focusing on the user which we do a lot
at Google but you might uncover some
really unmet needs and discover some new
ways of going about your work finally
again representing the amazing research
our team has done across Google this
year I wanted to synthesize just three
methods that we have found incredibly
useful with digital wellbeing research
one interview the 90th percentile user
you can really get a sense of where the
unmet needs lie when you're getting to
know who's not using your product
seconds consult experts critics and
brand trust data having a more objective
perspective really helps you see your
blind spots and then finally survey your
users and then check logs what we've
seen is that through surveys qualitative
feedback and surveys that doesn't always
line up with the actions people are
taking on the website or on that app so
correlating those two will really
uncover what is happening with their
user
behavior do they say they want to change
something and yet they're not actively
doing that and finding ways to make
those bridge is really important finally
I want to thank you first and foremost
for coming out very early this morning
to be with us I really appreciate that
you've come to Google to spend this time
together with this amazing community and
I hope that you'll get outside once it
gets sunny and take some time to just
enjoy this amazing week and experience
Joe Meaux as we like to call it and when
you get back to your desk we look
forward to working with you I'm building
an ecosystem that supports and
prioritizes digital well-being thank you
[Music]
you